Hi, I'm Alex Greer with the IBM Cloud team.
Today I want to talk aboutIBM Cloud Secrets
Manager. But, before I get into it, don't
forget to hit that "Subscribe" button!
As enterprises build more microservices and become
globally distributed, securing your application
secret data becomes much more complex. As we saw
before in my previous video, secrets management
services enable the secure management of digital
credentials that ultimately allow entities
to securely interact with services.IBM Cloud
Secrets Manager is a service based on open-source
HashiCorp Vault designed to securely manage
the lifecycle of Secrets, such as IAM API Keys,
User credentials, or different forms of arbitrary
text.This allows IT security leaders to dream big
about their cloud native application future
without being concerned about data breaches
from mismanaged credentials, or losing velocity in
their developer operations while securing secrets.
Secrets Manager centralizes the experience
ofgenerating, storing, rotating, and revoking
multiple types of secrets from a single pane
of glass. Integrations with other services such
as your private catalogs in IBM Cloud enables
the retrieval of your secrets in-context when
you need them, streamlining your workflows.
Through leasing, it even allows for you to give
an application or a team member temporary access
to a service to complete their respective task.
As a managed service, Secrets Manager offers much
of the same benefit of an on-premise deployment of
Vault without the hassle of having to maintain its
tricky operators, or manage and ultimately operate
its underlying infrastructure. This allows you
to keep your desired security posture at scale,
while we take care of the rest.A critical element
of Secrets Manager that makes it’s so powerful
is its unique trust model. Built for enterprises
that have very little tolerance for any sort of
data vulnerabilities but need the velocity
provided by the cloud. This model starts by
allowing you to seal your vault and encrypt all of
your hosted secrets with your own root encryption
key.For example — one of your existing
FIPS compliant keys from IBM Key Protect,
giving you ownership of your data. Next, your data
is protected in transit through TLS — Your vault
as well as the UI and APIs you use to interact
with it are all single-tenant. Meaning, your
data is isolated in your own dedicated silo and
doesn’t rely on any shared components. And…should
you decide to delete your instance you have the
peace of mind that your data is cryptographically
deleted. Thanks for listening to this introduction
of IBM Cloud Secrets Manager. To get started
with improving the security of your secrets
come check us out in the IBM Cloud catalog.